foreign
Phoenix hi Patrick welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so I am 20 years old and about two years
ago I moved to Phoenix Arizona to start
my own business selling furniture
I was straight out of high school and
I'm just like super young and I moved in
with my aunt and uncle
uh so it's been two years later now I
saved it back forty thousand dollars in
cash uh I'll have like another 30 Grand
in crypto
and I'm just wondering if it's a good
time to move out
okay how long you been listening Tosh
uh probably three or four years now I
actually met you in personal time okay
well are you going to take my advice
this time because you didn't on the
crypto
are you
yeah okay all right cash out to crypto
move out
get your life started okay you got 70
grand you're 20 years old you're kicking
butt
but get get the money out of there while
you still got it because it's going to
evaporate if you don't
and um okay yeah and then we're sitting
on 70 grand and you're making obviously
making some money what kind of money
you're making
uh I'll probably do about 100 Grand this
year wow what does selling furniture
look like what is that business model
uh so I go around picking it up clean it
up and then take really good pictures
and sell it
give me an idea of a margin on something
you've done recently what you bought it
for versus what you sold it for
uh so recently I bought an outdoor
sectional for 500 I pay someone 200 to
fix it up for me and then a couple days
ago I sold it for 26.50
700 would cost and he flipped it for
2600 bucks somebody's outdoor sectional
that just probably needed to be scrubbed
right
yeah right
where are you getting where are you
doing this work because you're living
with your aunt and uncle they're you're
not doing it in their garage are you
and so I actually just got uh two
Warehouse spaces I guess you did okay
dude you're a stud that is awesome I
absolutely love it you're a player yep
you're a player well done well done yeah
in another hour we read a question about
what we thought about Universal income
uh you know a stipend for people that
won't work and then you got a 20 year
old with a high school education that's
making a hundred grand flipping used
furniture
and some of you are standing around with
your finger in your ear
unbelievable American dream is alive and
well what a country yeah there it is
there it is
again folks wow yeah that's great what a
great guy I love you Patrick Yeah sell
the stupid crypto move out on your own
you get you a life you're doing great
proud of you well done
that is so great an outdoor sectional
you know 26 yeah I mean 2 600 bucks is
cheap for I mean that's a good
that's a good deal and oh my gosh that's
great
yeah I can just see him driving along
and something sitting on the curb
somebody's throwing it out to stay can I
have that yeah you know and put the leg
back on it and this is an example by the
way of
what it means to live in a very wealthy
country
people are throwing away essentially a
nice sectional he turns around and makes
really good cash on it he's taking what
other people are thinking is trash or
they're on they're moving on to the next
thing I gotta finance my outdoor section
I'll get something new he's making real
money it's a really interesting
commentary on where we are at in America
today but the opportunity to make
something of yourself is still there you
know what else I think about when I hear
somebody like Patrick show up his mom
and dad did a great they did they did
that's right they taught him to work
yeah they taught him how to work a
margin you know somebody did I mean
you're not born with that no you know no
you know I've been to the hospital they
always say you know it's a boy it's a
girl they don't say it's an entrepreneur
somebody taught him that you know that
you know wow here's something else too
this is special young man
but a lot of culture and society would
look down on him because he didn't go to
college he's laughing all the way to the
bank yeah he's two warehouses 250 000
and I got a master's degree in social
work and I make 38 000 at the state
right and I'm in dead up to my eyeballs
yeah that's that's just contemporary oh
my gosh